Many of us have tried growing a plant at home...
...and failed simply not knowing how.
We should be using technology not to disconnect but to connect with nature.
We introduce Planty,...
...the world's smartest garden pot.
Planty records and monitors your plant...
...and also analyzes the data to help you learn how to grow the plant...
...while being connected via Wi-Fi.
Growing a plant, flower or herb has never been easier.
Using the app, you can water your plant from anywhere at any time.
Check the temperature and humidity of Planty's environment.
And when you're busy, Planty will alert you when it's too cold, needs water or light.
Have fun and stay connected with others through Planty.